Yeah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah. Continuing
in
the book of
authored
In the chapters regarding the
signs and events just before the day
of judgment.
Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
[Silence]
Abu Huray narrates here a narration
which is in both Bkari and Muslim on the
authority of Abira.
or Abua narrates on the authority of
Abi. Is that what I just said? Okay, I'm
I'm just saying extra words right
now. So the narration is on the
authority of
and it's reported by Bkari Muslim
that the messenger of Allah
said I swear by the one in whom my life
is in his hand.
So I swear by the one
whom my life is in his hand. He's
swearing by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
His life, his nephs is in the hand of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
This is a common phrase that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam used in his
wording
of very important matters and something
really important would come up or
something that he wished that the
listeners would take particular note. He
would use words this. So he swears
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that the
dunya the life of this world will not
cease to be until a man will cross a
grave and find himself
almost
wrestling on top of the grave.
in the Arabic language.
[Silence]
And so what is meant here is that a
person will pass by a grave and
stop to appreciate and wish that he was
in this grave that he was in the place
of this person who is in the grave.
and he will say either verbally or to
himself, I wish that I was in this
person's place in the grave. The prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam then tells us why
he is wishing for death or wishing
that he had passed away or that he
was in this grave. It is not because
of anything except for the
fitan the fitan or the fitna
not being that he's having a hard
physical life. His physical life is
okay. There's no problem with his
physical well-being. He's comfortable
physically. The problem is is that he
his dean and his character and his
religion and his dutifulness to Allah.
These things are being constantly
challenged as the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam tells us that at the end
of
the time a person holding to his
religion, holding to what the prophet
and his companions were upon will be as
difficult and strenuous as holding on to
a lit ember, a lit coal, and a person's
hand, trying to hold on to it and keep
hold of it. And so in this narration we
have that this man is wishing for death.
What grave is it that we're talking
about? It's not the point.
It's not any specific grave. And what
person is the one who's going to be
making this wish? Again, not important.
This is just an example of how times
will be. Now does this mean that it is
permissible for a person to ask for
death?
The answer
is that our prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam tells us also in Bkari Muslim
he says
[Silence]
He said, "None of you is to ask for
death because of a a difficulty that he
is going through. If you must say
something, then you are to say, "Oh
Allah, give me life as long as life on
this earth is good for me and take me in
death if you know that death is good for
me."
We have
this narration here in which
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
says do not wish for death because of
some kind of difficulty that you are
afflicted with
it'll pass you have to be patient it'll
pass
we have here
she's afflicted with the hardship
in Allah tells us that she said
[Silence]
How how
before this?
Isn't there a difference between that
and oh Allah make me die right now?
[Silence]
and so there's two types of fitna here.
We have fitna because of a hardship.
The scholars agree it's not permissible
to ask for death because of that. Then
we have fitna
that puts a person's soul and dean at
hazard.
Is it permissible to make dua
for death in that instance?
This is a point of difference, a point
of contention amongst the scholars of
Islam that if a person is faced with a a
fitna that places their dean a hazard,
is it permissible to make dua for death
at that point? It's a difference of
opinion amongst the scholarship of
Islam. But this narration that we just
read, the narration of here, a man will
pass by the grave of another is a very
weak evidence in that argument
for either way. Why?
Because it's not the point of the
narration.
When a story is told,
when a story is told,
the point
is to be looked at the overarching point
and purpose that the reason that the
story is being told, not the individual
rulings that may be derived from the
story. That's a different topic
entirely.
So for instance, we have Yuisam. He's in
prison. He's got two men that come to
him and ask him to interpret his dream,
their dreams. And he mentions that one
of them is going to start to he's
going to get out and he's going to be
a trusted a trusted slave or servant for
the king and he's going to crush his
grapes for his wine.
But alcohol is haram.
Is that the point of the story? Is the
point of the story
the ruling of alcohol in Islam? Is that
the point of the story?
No. Point of the story is that two men
had a dream and he interpreted them.
That's the point of the story. The
details of the story. When a story is
told in order to give an overarching
u point or to drive home an overarching
theme, the details of the story are not
to be taken
in detail out of the context of that
story.
And so for this reason
when we have a story of a prophet, a
story of a messenger, a story of
something that happened in Bened,
something that will happen in the
future, the details, the individualized
details in that story are not to be
taken as evidences
for halal and haram because that's not
the reason why the story is being
related.
Understood? So for instance let's say
if if if we found
let's say we wanted to speak about
the dangers of
you know the dangers of of
not having a a lock on your door
ju just you know hypothetically. So,
I wanted to tell you guys a story, a
cautionary tale about someone who failed
to have a proper lock on his door. And
then in the story, let's say here in
Tucson, someone was able to easily break
into his house and harm him while he was
sleeping, him and his girlfriend and his
children.
Do we derive from a story that that
it is permissible for a person to have
children out of wedlock?
Think about it.
Do we derive from a story that, a
cautionary tale that the ruling
of a person having a girlfriend or
having a boyfriend?
Are those details the point of the
story? No. The point of the story is the
general theme. The specific details they
are not to be hung on
because that's not the center thrust of
the story. That's not the reason why the
story is being told. We come back to a
narration this. The prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam is telling
us that the day of judgment will be near
when people when good people will be
making dua for death because the fitna
on their dean will be so tremendous.
What's the point of this narration? What
is the prophet trying to say with this
narration with this story? What point is
he driving home?
He's trying to paint a picture of the
of the intensity of the fitna near
the end of time on a person's dean. He's
trying to paint a picture of how godless
people will be and how difficult it
will be to be a good person in a bad
world during those times. That's the
point of the story. the details of how
that point are expressed is not the
reason why he's telling the story. And
this is why a narration this
doesn't even really belong in
the debate of whether it is permissible
or not to ask for death when faced with
the calamity. It is one of the weakest
types of evidences in that kind of
debate because it is not the center
thrust of the reason why the story is
being told. We could find that in the
story of Sleman
the
he was given control of them. Correct?
And they used to make
statues for him. They used to fashion
statues to correct. Do we derive from
this that it is permissible or
impermissible for us to make statues of
living creatures? Is that a strong
evidence for yes or no in that
particular issue? No. Why? Because
that's not the purpose of those details.
What are the overarching purpose or what
is the overarching purpose of why Allah
tells us that detail? to show and to
give us an an idea of just how much
authority
was given over a and how skilled these
were. That's the reason why the story is
being told to us. It's not to tell us
whether fashioning is permissible or
impermissible. That's not even part of
the story really. That's just a a
passing detail. And that is why the
scholars of they refer to these types of
details as
[Silence]
Subhanahu
this is how they're supposed Just look.
means
it's too much.